bonjour à tous alors nous ne sommes pas
devant mais derrière la cathédrale de
chartres joyau de l'art gothique elle
est inscrite au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco depuis 1979
elle exerce une certaine fascination et
pas seulement sur les chrétiens ou sur
les férus d'architecturé puisqu'il
existe de nombreuses légendes autour de
ce monument
je vous propose d'en découvrir
quelques-unes suivez moi vous faire une
petite visibilité plutôt axé sur les
légendes et les histoires fait aussi qui
sont passés dans cette cathédrale des
légendes dans et surtout sous la
cathédrale clair la guide conduit son
groupe dans la plus ancienne crypte car
ce monument du xiiie siècle repose sur
les vestiges de six autres églises et
sur l'a6 des celtiques des carnutes la
légende raconte qu'il y aurait une
grotte peut-être même sous un dolmen ou
les droïdes aurait prié marie bien avant
sa propre naissance
bien sûr que c'est pas vrai
malheureusement c'est une légende qui a
commencé à être écrite partir du 12ème
13ème siècle par les chanoines et vous
pris par d'autres chanoine ensuite aux
16e et 17e siècles de manière à faire
venir un petit peu plus de pèlerins ici
plutôt qu'ailleurs c'est du marketing de
l'époque et ce n'est pas la seule
légende inventée pour attirer plus de
croyants et avoir plus de dos il existe
aussi celle du puy dessin fort les
chanoines avait affirmé que son nom
était miraculeuse mais pas seulement
on aurait mis les premiers martyrs
chrétiens dans le cuit et même des
moines
à cause des vikings trois hôtels vikings
h après ça c'est véridique
pendant la deuxième guerre guillemois
tuer la majorité du clergé et aurait mis
le corps des moines dans le puits donc
c'est une légende
d'ailleurs on le sait parce que en 2012
on a eu des fouilles qui ont été faits
dans le puits y sommes déjà au
spéléologue ils sont descendus dedans et
ils m'ont trouvé aucune molécule humaine
crée des légendes n'est pas l'apanage
des chanoines puisque dans les années
1960 un dénommé louis charpentier en a
aussi inventé autour de l'arche
d'alliance que l'on voit sur ce pilier
cette légende raconte que les templiers
auraient retrouvé à jérusalem
ce coffre qui contiendrait les dix
commandements arrivé ici il aurait caché
l'arche d'alliance en vain les
souterrains de la cathédrale c'est à
dire dans l'une des crises jeu sécrète
de la cathédrale selon les charpentiers
est ce que cette arche elle est encore
ici fait dans certains d'autres la
cathédrale va s'effondrer tout inquiet
requis on retrouver l'arche d'alliance
si ce monument génère autant de
fantasmes
c'est aussi lié à son architecture et à
ses dix mille statues dont celle de st
les légendes de ça veut dire ce qui doit
être lu en fait en latin et donc les
légendes ce sont les contes merveilleux
les comptes clients d'encoder dessins
des comptes qui ont une finalité de
soutenir le fidèle d'un insert fois
fidèle ou non ils sont chaque année un
million deux cent mille touristes à
découvrir la cathédrale et ses légendes
nous allons aller un peu plus loin sur
la question des légendes avec vous
emmanuel blondeau donc vous êtes le
recteur de la cathédrale pourquoi votre
avis il ya autant de légendes justement
autour de ce monument mais depuis lors
on y fait la même chose on y célèbre la
messe on y sert le seigneur tous que
c'est absolument incroyable
deuxième chose on se dit vu comment les
gens du moyen-âge au pu créer un tel
lieu donc sacré l'imagination et puis
troisième chose ya quand même des choses
qui qui nous étonne temple au portail
royal si vous regardez il ya les signes
du zodiaque est ce que ça fait là bas
c'était une manière d'exprimer les
synergies l'erc
et puis en parallèle les travaux des
champs et donc les signes du zodiaque
c'est une manière de marquer
de marquer l'année avec les travaux des
champs voilà donc il ya des choses comme
ça et qui qui sont à la fois des choses
étonnantes mais qui sont bien réels
quand on rentre dans la cathédrale
on reste pas on reste pas la porte on
est invité à s'avancer et à s'avancer et
on va croiser le labyrinthe de
labyrinthes d'abord celui sur ce qui
représente donc c'est un showman be et
au centre il y avait une plaque avec le
dessus these et minotaure et donc le
combat
le minotaure le mal these représente le
christ et voilà combien le christ au
coeur de nos vies vient vaincre le mal
est donc c'est un chemin de vie qui nous
invite à comprendre que notre vie est
les combats et le bruit et les combats à
l'est pas c'est pas une ligne droite
alors justement vous parlez de taizé du
minotaure qui
le biologique la mythologie grecque donc
rien à voir avec la chrétienté faut
imaginer que le moyen-age on a un temps
de de synthèse philosophique et
théologique
donc on reprend la mythologie grecque on
reprend la philosophie grecque
c'est d'un temps où on connaît aristote
c'est un temps libre on lit aristote et
donc tout ça s'est repris et donc c'est
intégré dans le la compréhension de ce
qu'est un homme
merci encore fernando c'en est fini
aujourd'hui pour les mystères et les
gens de la cathédrale de chartres et on
vous retrouve demain pour parler des
légendes des bords de loire